à l'assemblée nationale donc raymond
barre a évoqué cet après-midi la sphère
de la rue copernic le premier ministre a
appelé les français à faire preuve de
résolution et de sang froid en évitant
notamment de verser dans l'excès des
accusations sans preuve et du soupçon
généralisé au plan de la quête de
l'enquète il y à du nouveau témoin cette
phrase de christian bonnet répondants
cet après-midi ou député communiste
robert ballanger les enquêteurs
conduisent l'enquète dans toutes les
directions et le ministre de l'intérieur
a ajouté en s'adressant à monsieur
ballanger toutes les directions dont une
à laquelle vous ne pensez peut-être pas
une petite phrase qui mérite des
explications
rachid arhab la phrase de christian
bonnet à l'assemblée nationale ne fait
que confirmer les bruits qui circulent
depuis ce matin les enquêteurs
travailleraient sur de nouvelles pistes
des pistes qui ne se dirigerait plus
essentiellement vers l'extrême droite
visiblement l' enquête avance rapidement
deux autres informations importantes
sont venus confirmer ce sentiment
aujourd'hui ces deux informations sont
bien sûr pour l'instant à prendre au
conditionnel première de ces
informations
il semble bien que la bombe était placée
dans les sacoches de la moto garée à
quelques mètres de la synagogue
seconde information le propriétaire de
la moto aurait été identifié identifiés
ne veut pas dire repérer les policiers
sont très discret sur ce point ce que
l'on peut dire par contre c'est qu'il
est étrange que le propriétaire de cette
moto à la différence de tous ceux dans
le véhicule était garé ici rue copernic
que cette personne donc ne soit pas fait
connaître pour être indemnisé ajoutez à
la phrase de christian bonnet ces deux
informations viennent visiblement donné
un nouvel axe à lenquête policière